loulou chasse le de nourrir
les forêts sont peuplés de loup c'est ma
mission de les tuer pas la tienne oui
mais avant chasser ensemble ils louent
les ours même les draps gauche
[Musique]
c'est ainsi modibo le foie coeur avoue
fourrière
ces êtres qui parle avec les routes avec
ses pouvoirs magiques
[Musique]
tu peux sortir maintenant on pas repéré
à l'odeur est trompeuse
7 un blogueur
they look dans ton sommeil
l'éveil
là
[Musique]
reviennent m'est arrivé quelque chose ça
je vois c'est trop bien
ces nouveaux noms
c'est tout
fauré rétrécit chaque sou
des loups ce ne sont que des bêtes cette
nuit nous mettrons un terme à tout ça
les premiers à ta mère de veiller sur
toi
[Musique]
vous devez partir
jamais je leur fille sera la troupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à